yep this paddleboarder was arrested  after refusing to get out of the water  then maybe if you go out on the huge  across the USA and you're wearing a swim  shirt cause of your scrawny way police  in your way  cuz it's illegal to be served  in the USA  to replay  release  go check me  [Music]  brain  sagal to be sir  in the USA  you've been distancing from us now to  keep the spread rate down  the only places you've been going are  where there are no crowd  you're making sacrifice  or your community now put your hands on  your head because you are served they  just told me not to touch my face listen  [Music]  by some kid  but you're gonna jump a turbine in the  USA  [Music]